500 miles long are the Turks serious
about policing it or is it just very
easy to cross well I think they're more
determined than they used to be but it's
still rather porous it's such a long
border and there's not that many people
there and there are not all that many
Turks there they're mainly Kurds we look
down now suppose you could build a fence
you could build a fence but you need you
know good intelligence and a lot of
competent people to man the fence well
let's look at just where yesterday's
explosion that happened in the town of
Surak and I do apologize for my ceruse
my Turkish pronunciation there right by
combining which we've heard 32 people
died or were injured at a rally
supporting the reconstruction of the
town of kobani in Syria where there was
heavy fighting recently between is and
Kurdish fighters and Turkey's Prime
Minister Davutoglu has promised to
struggle that and stop Isis but it's
totally really serious about that
there's a problem here because the the
real number one enemy of Iran and Devoto
you the Prime Minister the Kurds
themselves getting autonomy in northern
Syria that's the number one fear the
number two fear is Assad sticking around
and it's only number three that they're
really fighting Isis and until Isis
becomes their number one priority are we
really going to have any plumbing in a
sense that raises the question if
they're more concerned about those other
threats than Isis what would be the
logic for us is bringing the fight into
Turkey well what's happened is that the
Americans and the others have persuaded
turkey to go along with the coalition
and one could argue this is retaliation
by Isis you're starting to crack down on
us we're going to hit you and I think
turkey is starting to realize that Isis
is very dangerous so they're making
adjustments in the last couple of weeks
they're starting to crack down on the
recruiters in Istanbul and Ankara but we
don't know for sure whether they're
going to be really serious because of
their priorities because you know the
main political pressure for Turkey is
that they could end up fighting along
the Kurds if you like and they're around
a third of turkeys population is Kurdish
concentrated in these areas along the
Syrian border and those are the ones who
make up the fighters but I as we know in
discussing alliances against the is the
problem is that arm the Kurds and the
Turks think the weapons might be turned
on there that's true and they're really
worried about any kind of autonomy or
independence in that northern Syria area
where kobani situated because that would
you know encourage those in the Kurdish
areas of Turkey to demand on autonomy
from Turkey so they're you know they're
in a tough position now we talked about
the problem of is coming across the
border into Turkey but of course the
other problem is people who want to join
is traveling into Syria and in June the
three girls from Bradford cross the
border between these two towns here
police estimate up to 700 people in
total have gone and 141 of them are
believed to have died with others coming
home so it is still possible to cross
this point it is indeed if the matter is
that they get to the border they're
gonna get across it the real question is
can you stop them from leaving say
Birmingham in the first place and here I
would say that Prime Minister Cameron's
speech in Birmingham yesterday was a
good start on trying to nip it at the
root cause okay because once they get to
the fence they're gonna get there the
other thing is can they be stopped
elsewhere in Istanbul at the airport
nearer to the border but once they get
to the border I think you've already
lost the battle okay Jonathan Parris
thank you very much indeed well it's